Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie!
So I was totally working on another video
and started making so many announcements
that I just need to make a separate announcements video.
So I hallucinated that it would be a good idea to do something called
The Emergencey Awesome Face Palm
and it'll be like a new weekly video series
where I make announcements,
talk about fun behind the scenes stuff that I'm working on
or if I like derp on some giant video
or there's some big error that I didn't see wherever I posted something
So just in general these videos will be a little more informal,
like, a little more vloggy.
I know a lot of you have asked me to start doing vlogs
and podcasty stuff
I'm not planning on doing a podcast any time soon
but I did need a video where I could just explain stuff
that didn't necessarily fit into
a Game of Thrones or a Star Wars video.
I'm hoping this is going to make it easier for me to do
episodes videos and movie videos
without having to cram a bunch of announcements into each of those.
Once I find a thumb nail design that I settle on
I'll make all the thumb nails the same
so it'll be really easy to find.
If you want to know what videos I'm going to be posting each week
or what I did last week it'll be really easy to find that.
I'll even put a playlist on the home page here
just so it's really easy for you guys to find
This is gonna be Face Palm #1
so next week I'll post Face Palm #2
So what I'm planning is on keeping these Emergency Awesome Face Palm videos
to 5 minutes in length
If I feel like it needs to be longer or something
I'll just do a live Twitch Q&A
or a stream or something like that.
I am planning on doing more streaming
if there is something that I'm planning ahead of time
I will mention it in one of these videos
So with that in mind,
here are the videos that I'm working on this week
So there is...
- let me look at my list here...
The Flash Episode #10, that's tonight.
The Last Air Bender Episode #3
That was gonna be -
- that was the other video I was working on
where I started making too many announcements.
That'll be tomorrow morning.
Then Arrow Episode #10
Then a Q&A for Flash/Arrow/DC stuff!
Then a new Marvel/Inhumans/Avengers video.
Then Constantine Episode #10.
Then a new Star Wars Bonus Video.
New Game of Thrones Bonus Video.
Then new Walking Dead.
And then Emergency Face Palm #2.
If something really crazy happens inbetween there
I might cram one in.
But those are the videos that I'm planning right now.
My biggest priorities this year are
#1 Keeping to my schedule!
So if I say I'm going to post Game of Thrones and Walking Dead on Sunday
I actually post those videos on Sunday.
What I'm working on is my video schedule follows the
TV schedule. So if something airs on a certain night
you can look for that video later that night!
The exception being, like, Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D for example.
There are a couple of nights a week
when there are a couple of different shows
and I can only make so many videos
in a certain amount of time.
So Shield Videos always post Wednesday mornings
Keeping my schedule would just mean
posting those Shield videos every Wednesday morning
at the same time.
I'm always changing little things about
the way I make videos.
So sometimes it takes me a little bit longer
to get stuff out.
Eventually I'm just gonna like settle on something.
So it'll be a little bit easier to hit that schedule.
Like, post the videos at the same time every day
Priority #2, this is actually a really big one,
is working subtitles!
Nothing bugs me more than Youtube derping subtitles
on the videos I post.
So, what I'm going to be doing is just manually
posting English subs for everything!
I partnered with Youtube to test out their
new Fansubs feature too
So now you can actually submit your own subtitles
for any of my videos.
It's kind of hard to find the menu.
But what you do is you click on the widget here
on the video page
and you click on this Add Subtitles button
It'll take you to the page where you can
transcribe your own subs.
Once you submit those and I see them
on the back end of my own channel I can enable them.
And Youtube has a thing where
it'll actually give you credit.
Anyone who submits Fansubs
for any of my videos will totally get shout outs
because you are automatically Awesome in my book!
All you guys who can't hear my videos really well
or don't speak English, you are really important to me.
So it's my hope that better subtitles
will make it easier for you to participate.
So that's really the important stuff:
You know, Better Subtitles. Sticking to the Schedule.
I know it sounds really simple.
I always find that it's less stressful
if you just make your goals really simple.
But those are two really important goals!
So the next edition of Emergency Awesome Face Palm
will be a little bit more fun.
There'll be more fun stuff.
There were just a few announcements
that I wanted to give out in this video.
There is some really cool stuff happening next week
and I will post the schedule in the video description
Generally, if you check the video descriptions,
usually that's where a lot of the extra information goes.
Like links for social and all that stuff
I'll be posting my video schedule to social too.
I'm trying to make special videos for that,
like really short videos for facebook, twitter, tumblr
all those other places.
And if there's something longer
that I wanna talk about
like if there's a Q&A that I wanna do
for a longer period of time,
I'll just do that on twitch.
If you have any special requests for
stuff you want me to include in these videos
just let me know in the comments.
I'm always happy to include stuff.
Just remember I'll be keeping the videos
below 5 minutes in length.
There's a whole lot of awesome stuff
happening this year that I'm really excited about!
Hopefully I'll have the opportunity to
make videos for most of it.
Even if I hit like half of it I'll be happy!
But, be sure to subscribe to get everything!
Next Emergency Face Palm will post next week.
If you haven't seen it yet
you can click here for my Gotham Episode
from last night.
And you can click here to get ready for
Arrow and The Flash this week!
Thank you so much for watching!
So lets all High Five!!
I will see you guys tonight!
*Music*